mientras Estados Unidos se debate entre
posibles restricciones al uso de la
píldora abortiva Argentina amplía su uso
luego de que la administración Nacional
de medicamentos alimentos y tecnología
médica aprobara en libre acceso de la
mifepristona el pasado marzo he visto
morir muchas chicas jóvenes que llegaban
con aborto sépticos y con insuficiencias
renales agudas que eran imposibles de
rescatar con shock
multisistémico y realmente cuando uno
tiene esa experiencia de vida
definitivamente quedas marcada y vas a
la búsqueda de esa solución Argentina
fue el más reciente país en dar luz
verde a la mifepristona reflejando una
expansión de los derechos reproductivos
junto con países como Colombia Bolivia
México y chile donde el medicamento ya
Es legal mientras que en otros como Perú
Brasil y El Salvador sigue prohibido o
su acceso es muy restringido la
bifeprissona se combina con misoprostol
logrando un 96% de efectividad y es
utilizado en más de la mitad de todos
los abortos en Estados Unidos
si uno le está indicando misoprostol
solo uno le tiene que decir a la mujer
que la tasa de falla es del 15%.
mientras que ahora con la mifepristona
uno le tiene que decir solamente la tasa
de falla es de un 3% en Estados Unidos
el medicamento fue aprobado por la
administración de drogas y alimentos fda
en el año 2000 pero recientemente grupos
antiaborto buscan prohibir el
medicamento argumentando que la agencia
gubernamental se equivocó e ignoró
supuestos riesgos para la salud